كيف تصف الوضع الميداني في خانيونس ابتداء
في الساعات
الاخيره في الساعات الاخيره نعم كان
الهدوء نسبي في محافظه خان يونس لكن تجددت
الغارات خلال الساعه الاخيره بينما اتحدث
معكم هناك اطلاق نار من قبل الرشاشات
الثقيله التي تطلقها طائرات الاحتلال في
الاجزاء الشرقيه من محافظه خان يونس
والغارات تجددت طبعا مع القصف المدفعي
اضافه الذي تطلق ف اليات الاحتلال قذائفها
باتجاه اهداف مختلفه وعديده في المناطق
التي تتمركز فيها الاليات وتطلق هذه
القذائف باتجاه اهداف عديده خاصه في
الاجزاء الشماليه من وسط محافظه خانيونس
وكذلك في المناطق الشرقيه للمحافظه وهذه
المناطق تشهد عمليات توغل لاليات الاحتلال
وتطلق القذائف وكذلك اطلاق النار بشكل
كثيف وعنيف احيانا في هذه المناطق الغارات
التي نفذت في خانيونس قبل تقريبا ساعه كان
هناك غارتين نفذته ما طائرات الاحتلال في
مناطق شرق محافظه خنوس كذلك في المناطق
الشماليه لوسط المحافظه لم تحدد طبيعه هذه
الاستهدافات وهاتين الغارتين تحديدا في
تلك المناطق لكن هذه المناطق كما هي مسرح
عمليات ليات الاحتلال فهي مستباحه لقوات
الاحتلال وتقوم بعمليات قصف مدفعي عنيف
احيانا اضافه الى استهداف من قبل طارات
الاحتلال المقاومه الفلسطينيه في ظل هذا
التصعيد الاسرائيلي ايضا تتصدى لمحاولات
التوغل التي تقوم بها اليات الاحتلال في
اكثر من محور في مناطق خانيونس خاصه في
الاجزاء الوسطى للمحافظه حيث تقوم بالتصدي
بعبر قذائفها التي تطلقها من مضادات
للدروع اضافه الى عبوات
محليه الصنع تستخدمها المقاومه الفلسطينيه
من اجل التصدي لاليات الاحتلال التي تحاول
التوغل في وسط المحافظه وكذلك عبر الكمائن
التي تنصبها في المناطق الشرقيه لمحافظه
خانيونس في بلاغات عده المقاومه
الفلسطينيه سواء كتائب القسام سرايا القدس
الويه الناصر وكتائب شهداء الاقصى وغيرها
من هذه الفصائل اعلنت عن تصديها لاليات
الاحتلال وجنود الاحتلال واستهداف هؤلاء
الجنود باسلحه مختلفه و وكذلك اطلاق النار
باتجاه جنود الاحتلال اطلاق قذائف باتجاه
ايضا اليات الاحتلال كل هذا ياتي في اطار
التصدي من قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه لهذا
العدوان الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه
الانفجارات في هذه اللحظات لم تتوقف في
الاجزاء الشماليه الشرقيه للمحافظه وكذلك
في الاجزاء الغربيه للمحافظه هذه ال
انفجارات ناتجه عن قصف مدفعي في كثير من
الاحيان اضافه الى اطلاق صواريخ من قبل
طائرات الاحتلال باتجاه اهداف عديده في
المحافظه طارت الاحتلال لا تغادر اجواء
قطاع غزه بشكل عام اجواء خنوس ايضا موجوده
بكثافه وعلى مستويات منخفضه وهذه الطائرات
ايضا سواء طائرات الاستطلاع تشارك في
العمليات القتاليه باطلاق الصواريخ اطلاق
النار احيانا هناك طائرات مسيره تطلق
النار باتجاه المواطنين في ساعات الصباح
دائما يتحرك المواطنون اي يعني حركه
المواطنين تكون محدوده
في في ساعات النهار لكن في ساعات الليل
تنعدم الحركه للمواطنين في بعض المناطق مع
ساعات النهار حركه المواطنين يعني فيها
شيء من الخطوره في بعض المناطق التي تشهد
فيها توغل الاليات الاحتلال وهنا يعني في
في كثير من الاحيان يتعرض المواطنون في
بعض المناطق التي يتحركون فيها لعمليه قصف
واطلاق نار من قبل طائرات مسيره تطلق
النار باتجاه هؤلاء المواطنين اضافه الى
ذلك هناك المناطق الشرقيه وهي مناطق
محاصره تماما من قبل اليات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وتمنع وصول المواطنين الى
منازلهم الا عبر طرق التفافه يسلكها
المواطنون من المناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه
للمحافظه وهذه تنطوي عليها خطوره بالغه في
حركه المواطنين باتجاه تلك المناطق هناك
استهدافات يستهدف فيها الاحتلال المواطنين
سواء باطلاق القذائف المدفعيه او حتى
الطائرات المسيره تطلق صواريخها باتجاه
هؤلاء المواطنين وتوقع بينهم اصابات
وشهداء في كثير من الاحيان اضافه الى ان
المنطقه الشرقيه كما هي محاصره هناك عدد
من المدارس داخل تلك المنطقه تاوي نازحين
في بعض المناطق خاصه في منطقه عبسان
الكبيره هناك مجمع للمدارس ياوي نازحين
يعيشون ظروف ماساويه وصعبه جدا في ظل
استمرار هذا الحصار على المنطقه
الشرقيه هناك لا لا يصلهم الماء والغذاء
الا بالقليل عبر محاولات ينفذها المواطنون
وسلوك طرق التفاف للوصول الى هؤلاء
المواطنين والنازحين داخل هذه المدارس
هناك مدارس تم اقتحامها من قبل قوات
الاحتلال خلال الايام الماضيه وقامت قوات
الاحتلال باعتقال عدد من المواطنين خاصه
الرجال منهم وكذلك تسريح النساء باتجاه
المناطق الغربيه لمحافظه خان يونس